welcome back to CBS mornings we've had
so much fun this week checking in with
people that we've introduced you to over
the past few years with the goal of
answering just one pretty simple
question
how are you now
this morning we visit with a former
media executive Ron King
he was forced to say goodbye to his
high-powered position covering High
fashion but in losing his job he found
himself in a really unexpected Place
surrounded by donkeys
among the coastal Hills of Northern
California right in the middle of wine
country
my favorite part of my day is my donkey
Hood
Ron King has created a Donkey Sanctuary
it's the weight of the head that lets
you know he is like happy
this is so sweet this 75 acre ranch is a
non-profit dedicated to their rescue and
Rehabilitation they're intelligent and
they have very high emotional
intelligence I give them love and they
give me love back I'm a donkey guy now
it's a far cry from his pre-pandemic
life a tired and Gucci shuttling between
New York and Los Angeles as a senior VP
for time Inc he managed sales and
marketing for some well-known Brands was
there a moment in your life where you
thought damn I've made it yeah I think
it was when you know I was flying first
class him alone to sit front row at
Versace that was a big deal but in 2018
the sale of time led to the elimination
of King's position so he freelanced but
then covet hit the work dried up and the
despair set in
then came a call from an old friend Phil
Selway a prominent pop art dealer he
hired Ron to move to his Ranch and sell
it because it wasn't being used I
thought it would be a win-win he could
help me tremendously and it would help
him give him another project King took
the job and while hiking around the
property he felt something new this
sense of calm my head is always like a
snow globe that's being shook it never
stops that sense of sort of Chaos in my
head was just normal for me when the
snow globe stops after 20 years you feel
that but you were still enough to
recognize it that's still enough to
recognize it and respectful enough to
act on it I had no thoughts in my head
except this beautiful surrounding and I
realized it's the first time I felt
Serenity in 20 years
well Serenity met Serendipity King
discovered a story about the plight of
donkeys known historically as strong
pack animals capable of hauling Goods
but they've outlived their usefulness so
donkeys which can live around 30 years
are sold at auction slaughtered and then
skin for their hides to be used for
traditional Chinese medicine they don't
have any Advocates they don't win Races
they don't feed a food chain and I
thought
I need to help donkeys so I said bill
I have an idea that I want to run by you
I want you to take it off the market not
sell it and let me turn this into a
Donkey Sanctuary that sounds bananas and
he he will tell you he also said it
sounded bananas the first thing I
thought when Ron was giving this
presentation was that he was crazy and I
would be crazy to go along with this
it's absolutely blown me away and I
could not be happier
donations support their cause every
donkey here would have been killed
patches was dying of starvation the only
way to help a donkey that's been abused
emotionally recover is to love it back
to health and I had this moment where I
realized that there's a difference
between things that I enjoy and things
that bring me joy and I was 52 years old
when I realized those are two different
things it's a whole different way of
living you will never be this sick again
and in helping donkeys to heal he may be
healing his own invisible scars King's
struggles began at an early age when
this son of a Southern Baptist preacher
first realized he was gay they were
young and they were religious and they
had a little [ __ ] boy so that didn't go
well all I really wanted all along was
to matter come on by his twenties he was
homeless addicted to drugs and alcohol
he got sober only after surviving an
overdose
understanding the power of resilience
you wanted to take the donkeys hiking
yes sir keep these guys fit Chang
rebuilds the donkey's strength and Trust
so that they're ready for adoption for a
long time proving that I could be
someone or be something motivated me
that part has gone but I want to matter
to the world to the donkeys to
people
you know changing lives may be a heavy
burden for a lot of people
but it is a load that these animals seem
to haul with Grace I was pretty
accomplished by all those standards
and I found myself with the rug pull out
from under me and for that level of
Despair to be so close so recent is
really an important lesson in resilience
and and turnaround
good morning there is light at the end
of the tunnel and it's not always a
freight train
sometimes it's
donkeys that was seven months ago Ron
how are you now yeah things are going
great we have been flooded with
donations and volunteers and adoptions
so it's been super busy and super fun
she is brand new here she's just
learning to trust us with the surge in
donations they've gone ahead and built
five new pins for quarantining animals
when they arrive that's to protect the
health of the herd
we've taken in five donkeys in the last
three weeks do you still feel like what
you were doing matters what I really
realized is as long as we stay true to
what we're doing and why we're doing it
that that mattering starts to amplify
and then we now have 91 volunteers all
of our volunteers share how much they
feel like they matter and his
vulnerability struck a chord he was
invited to share his story with a group
of medical professionals who help
troubled teenagers I really spoke about
different ways in which teens could feel
like they matter why mattering is of
such importance as you know I was a
struggling teen and so that was really
meaningful to me
baby girl it's never too late for a new
start and chasing Joys it's Amplified
out to literally thousands of people and
once that happens you really feel like
you're making a difference oh my baby
[Music]
such important lessons there here's the
takeaway there's a difference he says
between things that I enjoy and things
that bring me joy it's good I think the
most impactful part though is that and I
think many people feel this way is that
you think that you have it all you want
to be somebody but it's really when it
comes down to it you just want to matter
that's right you know Oprah says we all
want to know do you hear me do you it is
what I have to say matter yeah that's
what they say people listen I'm sorry go
ahead I was gonna say people clearly
heard your story he says got donations
coming in there are new uh partnership
volunteers coming in yeah I love the
pride he takes him wearing that shirt
that says staff on the back I love it
even thank you so much all week it's
been awesome